stéphane emploi de ce petit chemin dans
un quartier reculé de rivière salée
depuis plus de cinq ans pour s'adonner à
l'une de ses passions la pêche au crabe
c'est dans ce terrain marécageux que cet
agent de sécurité suit les traces de son
père lui aussi pêcheur de crabes celui
qu'il appelle affectueusement pablo n'a
jamais loupé une saison de pêche depuis
plus de 50 ans expert il a sa méthode
tout fait pour empêcher plus au monde et
bien bloqués à bord et ce n'est pas le
coup vite 19 qui viendra perturber leurs
plans d'autant plus que la demande est
toujours au rendez vous la lazio
van damme sont jaloux maladif libournais
en croyant pas quitter nos clients et
puis c'est le coteau mon coin c'est un
cap élevé à dubaï ou ça casse sacré chez
céline nos pêcheurs ont quand même perdu
une grande partie de leur clientèle
composée essentiellement de
restaurateurs fermé depuis la mise en
place du confinement
ils se sont donc organisés afin de
répondre à la demande des habitués y en
a qui viennent directement sur place
nous habituer il y en a que des vidéos
qu'on a fait parce ils appellent ils
demandent ce qu'il ya possibilité
d'incliner donc du coup je fait la
moitié du chemin pour leur permettre
d'avoir le déplacement sont contre
une demande que stéphane et son père
devait pouvoir largement satisfaire dans
leur enclos les deux hommes ont pu
capturer plus d'un millier de crabes
de quoi permettre à de nombreuses
familles martiniquaises de pincer pour
bon matutu malgré le confinement